far from palaces
pomp and princes
but no less part of a nation's mourning
churches like this one in warwick today
joined him with 96 chimes marking every
year of the late queen's life
solitary bells
in small parishes
felt deeply moving
[Music]
as millions began to reflect on the
queen's singular life
my little girl was born just eight weeks
ago and
i'm i feel really glad that she was born
during queen elizabeth's reign um sadly
she won't grow up sort of knowing her in
the way i did i'm here because she
reminds me so much of my mom
and i live part-time in australia
and part-time here in uk
so i'm privileged to be here
at this moment
across the country today were signs of
this time
a time a transition most of us have
never seen reflected in ways we might
not have expected
[Music]
a manchester cathedral some stopped just
to be part of it
but others came out of a sense of
genuine loss jeffrey miller met the
queen when he was 12 and an army cadet
in wales he's still in shock
i couldn't believe it
you know i just stood in the front room
i
must admit there were tears coming down
my eyes
she was my queen she's my
commander-in-chief she'd always been
there ever since i've
been alive
everything about her was service to
others
manchester was the last cathedral the
queen visited back in july last year the
dean remembers her delight when he
presented her with the cathedral's own
honey which they'd heard she light in
her tea
i found her very flexible and able to
relate to
people at all levels
very pleasantly
always engaging always interested
and always with a smile on her face
nothing was too much for her
she has been the nation's constant a
poll carried out in 2018 found that a
third of people across the uk had met or
seen the queen in person
over the coming days and weeks you will
see more places like this established
across the country some big some like
this one small but all places for people
to come together to lay flowers to
reflect and remember a woman who they
may never have met but with whom
everyone you speak to feels a deep
connection and with her passing a deep
sense of loss
and with loss comes for some uncertainty
about the monarchy's future
it's uh
it's a great loss
great launcher
i just hope that
charles can live up to
what his mother has obviously instilled
in him
that'll be a wonderful legacy for him to
carry forward
and what a legacy 70 years on the throne
forever in hearts
catherine rivertotsi sky news in
manchester